game
first blitz game and it's a kingsborne
opening from duda aronian nearly always
replies uh in this way as black and wow
we see a very aggressive line of the
italian game maybe not the most topical
these days normally white takes a slower
approach what do you think guys this is
going to heat up right yeah definitely
it's one of those variations that are so
tricky that black must know how to
respond to this so this is a good move
to counter-attack the bishop
and
black moves the knight backwards yeah
this is a bit rare normally black's
knight jumps into the center of the
board
uh but for sure both players have
studied this one actually this is one of
the oldest variations uh at least it was
until a couple of moves ago one of the
oldest variations uh opening variations
in chess
white is the first castle black needs to
do the same the black king is not going
to be happy in the center things are
going to open up
and uh now white temporarily upon down
is he going to try and regain that pawn
we see levon aronian hovering there if
we see his screen he's hovering over one
of his knights he's assuming that white
is going to capture a pawn in the center
with his knight
okay no instead that knight is captured
and he's retreating one of his pieces
clearly both players have studied this
before
because uh retreating the knight back to
starting square so bizarre
it's very incredible if somebody doesn't
play these openings i'm like what
just like what are you doing
it's like the night from g8 actually
went over and occupied its sibling
starting square that's kind of unusual
let's see it happen too often yeah
that's true that night looks like it
hasn't moved it's actually started on
the other side of the
board this is what puts me off playing
these lines as black there's so many
different variations you have to learn
you really need to know your stuff
if you don't know one move you can get
smashed right so i mean i wouldn't have
found knight b8
that's just not a move that there's a
similar idea i guess in the french
defense an opening you play maybe um but
right yeah okay we just do see a trade
of pieces there and i was gonna say
finally black can castle but nope he
offers a queen trade first
uh both players are playing very quick
but just the speed with which levon has
made these moves black tends to be doing
completely fine in these openings if he
knows what he's doing and clearly he
knows what he's doing
so i think the opening has been a
success for him and that night sitting
on the b8 square at home is getting
ready to redevelop itself
he looks very calm very zander ironian
normally he's kind of gesturing he's a
bit more expressive but
no he's super focused yeah and would you
say black's position is easier to play
because to my eyes i'm thinking
especially if the queens are traded off
i i like what
black's position is like you know he has
an open lines good pieces and this is
why
rangyan christoph just moves his queen
over to the h5 square
but
it does look a little bit artificial
like it's white has got only one active
piece
i mean take a look at those pieces on
the left
knight and bishop's still on the
starting squares yeah there's a massive
disconnect between white's queen and the
rest of her army the rest of her army
are completely asleep it's as if they've
forgotten to join the battle and he
needs to wake those pieces up now
also the speed it just feels like
aronian's a bit more quick
right now he's a bit more confident
and
yeah it's early days but you were saying
simon this type of opening i think i was
on that massive learning curve
throughout my first uh five ten years of
playing chess i would lose countless
games just to this type of opening and
it took a long long time to realize you
know what you should do how to avoid any
risk here and levon's found one of the
paths
yeah go back and uh look at this one
myself yeah he's very very experienced
isn't he levon i mean now obviously in
all the e4 e5 he's probably one of the
best
players if not the best player
who plays one e5 nearly exclusively um
but it's just like for someone like me
who's in my 40s i'd love to learn one e5
because it's such a good move but i
really can't be bothered to learn all
this stuff it's just like it's too much
and seeing these lines which are obscure
lines it terrifies me the process of
learning this you have to be extremely
dedicated to uh to and also just to
remember all the lines you know i mean
can i can i remember this stuff now i
don't know
with the last move now black opening up
the position and i i really like black's
position here
yeah very thematic you know i have uh
in my 20s i started this position one of
these type of positions with a white
side and uh if black could usually get
this pawn break then with an open
f line then they were having a great
time yeah and it's also just about the
fact that white's pieces aren't fully
ready so um it follows classical wisdom
levon's a very classical player if the
opponent's pieces aren't ready here
we're looking at white's pieces
especially on this left side if they're
asleep if they're on their starting
squares open things up accelerate the
nature the kind of pace of the game and
that's what he's doing and white's
knight is doing a little dance here
i think his idea is to
okay i was going to say try and force
some kind of repetition of moves but
enough for a queen trade by levon
ironian if white says no to this he's
going to lag behind even more in
development but duda it's his style to
keep queens on the board so what will he
do maybe trading queens is the safest
but he'll be reluctant to do that
especially with white
but also it does feel like that white
knight
is on the wrong circuit to be honest i
mean it can't really jump to an
effective square
behind enemy lines maybe yeah and you
kind of feel like if there is a queen
trade and the s as it's happened that
that knight could be vulnerable
yeah quite possibly white just needs to
get his bishop out there get that bishop
con
off the first rank connect the rooks
you need your rooks connected you need
them to be flexible how calm is lev on
ironian just
leaning back in his chair
such an important blitz game as well
i think so he got asked but whether he
gets nervous in a previous tour and he
just said no i just simply
i mean he just doesn't get nervous he's
so experienced i mean he's had so many
uh
stressful encounters over his life it it
probably just doesn't affect him anymore
um i mean he's he's won two world cups
more than anyone else in world cups
they're fast they're ferocious knockout
tournaments where you have to play rapid
chess you have to play blitz chess uh
tie breaks and he's navigated those
successfully for his whole career so
yeah one of the most experienced
warriors left on the tour
and uh okay this knight moved by dude uh
i quite like just holding things
together jovanka you mentioned the night
wasn't necessarily on a great square
and aronian says okay you can't take my
bishop no exchanges for you
but at least now black's pawn structure
with the doubled c pawns
could potentially become loose
uh if white can activate his pieces but
it's a big if right now also duda 30
seconds more than 30 seconds behind on
the clock doesn't seem like much but in
blitz chess could be a factor gaining
only only three seconds after every move
hey wow this is dude's style again he's
so forceful he wants to force the issue
on every turn
so he's traded a set of pawns he's lured
away black bishop from the center so
that he could capture
uh still level pawns but i'm expecting
the other black rook now to join the
action black is going to be playing with
four pieces white is going to be playing
with only two two of which pieces still
asleep there we
go yeah it feels like momentum wise it's
it's black it's ironian yeah it
certainly does you know
and uh dude are just on the defensive
and it's not easy to handle those two
active rooks i mean i was thinking
knight c3 but then i think knight takes
pawn works
and in that variation i'd love to bring
my knight back defend some squares but
this could be actually a pretty nasty
tactic if it works i haven't i think it
works but i'm still saying that there's
a really bizarre bishop d2 check yeah
maybe i'll quickly show this uh just
because you have a spare moment dude
he's under huge pressure his knight is
attacked if he chooses the most natural
retreat a safer square then simon points
out maybe black and grabber pawn because
here there will be a rook check the
white king forced out into the open and
i mean at the very least i think he can
just take this bishop but uh maybe even
better discover check and white's king
in massive trouble so uh okay he hasn't
fallen for that trap but instead he's
walked into a self pin massive tension
on this line let's go back to the
players it's definitely duda on the
defensive
he's clinging on for now yeah one minute
down on the clock yeah and uh big threat
on the position white is actually
threatening to put the knight on the f6
square give a check to the king and
capture the rook on e8 yeah
so aronian just has to make sure that
all of his pieces are defended that's
maybe the one flaw in black's setup is
that he does have some loose pieces the
black rookers ivanka mentioned there the
e8 square okay run away now to safety
black's knight as well slightly loose
you don't want loose pieces with no time
on your clock that's when things that's
when bad things happen
but now white central pawn the isolated
pawn in the middle there might be
dropping off
still black trying to make things happen
yeah it's also getting down to a minute
now dude as well and as you're saying
it's it's quite hard to adjust to the
time limits right they're playing 15
minutes they get less increment now
and that that does make a much more
difference in these these time controls
when you get short
so you're going for this and things
getting simplified though now yeah but
black has won a pawn yeah yeah black's
pawn structure on the queen side not the
best black does have three pawns versus
two on that left side but two of them
are isolated uh sorry two of them are
doubled all three of them are isolated
and uh dude they're just eyeing up some
of those black pawns
who would you take here
um
the black
black pieces extra porn i'm a
materialist i like it was it you though
who told me ivanka that rook and bishop
worked better than rook and knight yes
so yeah it's
black does have the extra pawn but white
has maybe the better kind of combination
of pieces yeah
and
well lavonne gives
gives his king a little square and also
kicks back the bishop i like this move
and where will the bishop go to perhaps
it has to retreat and attack the rook
yeah the rook moves to safety and uh
yeah if all of the rooks come off if
black can centralize his king the extra
pawn will start to count
so maybe uh some quite clever play here
from aronian but
dude is still rock solid with white i'm
expecting a set of one rook trades and
then the white king can start
centralizing maybe
still it's not easy to win back that one
for white and uh what about this duda is
now under a minute he has 39 seconds
left on the clock clock is ticking and
knights are really crafty pieces because
they're somehow with the way that they
move it's difficult to gauge
and uh now
duda just uh relocates his bishop to the
long diagonal
yeah really nice move that bishop is not
gonna get kicked away any time soon and
they have of course been used to the
whole day
in rapid chess to 10 seconds increment
but now in the blitz they only get three
seconds
so that clock will now take very fast
for young christophe duda
aronian i mean the speed he's been
playing is super impressive yeah
normally there's this kind of
this cliche this myth that older players
maybe struggle with blitz but
not in erroneous case
okay he's jumped in with his knight now
there has been this exchange
maybe this game
will fizzle towards a draw duda though
offering a trade of pawns here
and black's king is coming i love this
move from irony not being greedy not
trying to cling onto his extra pawn
giving the pawn back in order to gain
two moves for the black king to rush
towards the center black's king is
winning the race uh compared to the
white king
at the moment
yeah black black certainly has the
better chances here um um and the better
time at the moment so
it'd be a big win with black pieces we
managed to take this one uh you know
what i think
lavon is going to win this i mean the
black king is coming in he's kept the
pawn as well he has kept the pawn
and
why did he do that one though yeah i was
expecting the king to come in and join
the rook and
he has gone for a different approach
maybe this is the idea repeat the
position
once
yeah
and uh then kind of
commit to the king strange but yeah it's
white really struggling here at the
moment 20 seconds on the clock as well
and well this is the big thing bring the
king in now surely surely the king comes
max king defends everything in the
center of the board it comes yep
and now one extra pawn and one almost
one extra minute on the clock duda he's
never gonna uh well he's always gonna be
in time trouble now he's never gonna
feel safe on the clock
just give a check with the blackrook now
you have choice of two squares
keep that blackrook safe if you can
he's kept that extra pawn that's the
important thing he's now i'd say a
relatively safe pawn up in this position
and uh you know
that counts
definitely yeah but there's one big
trick on the position that he has to
think about and i was going to say after
ponte's pawn there is the possibility of
white giving a check with a rook
but that seems to be under control yeah
if white gives a track black's king
would just move towards that white rook
and uh win the game so um okay we will
see an imbalance of pawn structure black
is now two pawns up but white's rook is
on that dream seventh rank hitting a
couple of pawns
is it time for a race i think black's
poorness are so quick though aren't they
i mean uh
you know
black can just defend and push surely
yeah i mean put the rook to defend the
sea pawn okay he's gone back with the
king same idea though it is the a pawn
that is going to be racing but
i mean they say connected past pawns are
very good but
in in these kind of race situations it's
just who's got the most advanced pawn
and black's pawn is nearer to queening
the whites pawn and i think that that is
probably going to be deciding factor now
that pawn it's it's so close now
three squares away from promotion
is alone though
it can be stopped it is alone yep it's
true the black king is going to come
and
yeah it's still a race it's still not
completely clear no not easy now
especially because the white pawns are
also kind of
this is great defense i mean put you in
a rook ending
if your opponent's got to pass pawn try
to get your rook behind the passport and
this is basic 101 chess when you're
trying to play these endings so just
remember that rook behind very hard to
push and yeah i
i think it's
he won the game now yeah it really is
isn't it i mean how about that other
black pawn can that start pushing you as
well you can and erroneous now he's
calculating does there we go you
predicted it wow
i was going to say he's either going to
start pushing the black king or he's
going to start pushing that black pawn
but white's pawn suddenly only three
squares away as well i think he's going
to bail out with a draw yeah shaking his
head too much risk this race now is too
close white's pawn is too far advanced
i think his big mistake aronian was
putting the black king so far away from
his pawn he should have brought the
black king earlier he had time to uh
bring it down and here we're going to
see a repetition of the position
is dude going to play for the win wow
okay he's moving his king away
if black gives another check is he going
to try and hide the white king now i
think he might do that incredible but
then you can always go rook back one
square to
draw easily
yeah there we go the end of the fun it
is a draw but a missed opportunity for
iranian ah with the black pieces as well
that was the first blitz game a draw in
five minutes blitz game number two will
start and levon ronian will have the
white pieces so would you say